well hi guys where are
each of you and who are you quarantined
with i'm back at my place we decided to
go back i was with chase and klein but
after
about a month times we were like it's
safe now to go back to my place so i'm
back at my apartment i'm in charleston
i have one of my friends uh i'm in uh
la2
i'm up in like the valley area with my
family what is life for you guys right
now i mean this show
dropped it's a huge instant success it's
amazing
so how are you doing with all of that i
guess like you know we just kind of
made show a show with our friends and
the fact that it's getting accepted like
this is like
pretty unbelievable i was just like
shell shocked
at the fact that it's it's happening and
to be honest i don't really feel like
it's actually happening because all we
have for proof is
social media and phone calls are being
like yeah it's doing really good and
then you look on instagram or stuff and
you're like wow yeah no there's a lot
of people watching it you know but
that's all it is really
it's wild i feel like you can see the
number of people
following you but i can't picture that
amount of people standing in a room
so it feels it feels like such a
disconnect
in a way i feel super normal in every
other way
and i see that number like that's so
crazy
i do want to talk about the season and
that finale
so first of all each of your reactions
to the finale did you
see that coming how did you react when
you read the script
i reacted being like no way like
is he dead because there was actually
multiple endings and we weren't sure if
jump we wanted to end with gumby
and the pugs knowing he's alive or
knowing that he's dead
and i like the way that we went
with a giant cliffhanger that the popes
do not know if he's alive and actually
believe he's dead so i was just like
dang that sets up
season two fingers crossed what's their
dynamic at first they were missing
basically the glue to their friendship
so it's like
that just sets up a lot everybody i call
let them know that you okay
i don't really have anybody to call i am
curious
why you guys think that john b chose not
to call the pogues because he had the
opportunity
to do something yeah yeah yeah you know
what
yeah like good point good point you know
what we were wondering that ourselves
you don't know if anybody could tap
those phone calls you know
i'm sure their parents like wouldn't
allow them to just kind of call and like
yeah maybe they didn't know where we
were
after that maybe we were in custody with
the police and they were like well i
can't call them like
they want to keep it on the download
they probably didn't have any phones
called because their phones are all
waterlogged
yeah oh yeah rudy what do you think jj's
dad
is gonna do or say when he finds out
that his boat
is underwater fingers crossed he doesn't
go back home
it's not gonna be pretty but i think
there is a weird
for me as the actor of jj not jj himself
of
maybe luke gets an arc of
in in season two where he has the
opportunity to forgive jj
or like later on because he's not gonna
be like
you know what i know why you did that
and i'm proud of you
you know like that's just not gonna
happen yeah no
you know fingers crossed that there's
going to be an arc for luke
in particular to forgive jj for people
really really hate watching jj go
through what he goes through with his
dad do you think that there's any sort
of
like goodness in his dad's heart like
could he get sober in season two
could we learn more about the back story
is that something that you would like to
see
yeah it's something i would like to see
but i don't think
right now the person i'm worried about
is jj himself because i think
luke is a little beyond the point of
addiction that's how
he escapes now and it's he is but i'm
actually more worried about jj and
he using substances for his pain for his
best friend being dead
and you know trying to cope with the
fact that he can't go home he can't go
see his dad because he's so afraid of
what's going to happen
but that opens doors with pope that
opens doors with key
to like get closer to them and i think
that could be an arc as well of like
maybe jj goes off the rails at first but
then his
friends pope and key are there for him
and that before
like my mom said you could stay at my
house
you know right oh yeah i've been
gathering i said you go
i agree yeah i agree with that it's
funny because i've been getting a lot of
adoption
uh requests on in social media and i'm
like you know it's not it's not
me right i'm like like i'm a grown man
speaking of pope and key people really
like you guys together
how do you feel about what they sort of
went through and where the relationship
goes from here
i guess from like pope's perspective
like yeah it's like he didn't really
expect that back from key especially
after you know she kind of rejected him
really hard
that's like one of the most interesting
things personally like
in a relationship wise with season two
is like how is that relationship gonna
play out you know like
will they get closer i think the idea of
pope still being like desert storm mode
don't give a crap about anything isn't
why isn't why kiara likes him he like
she likes you know the weird the weird
pope and it's like
i think her trying to get him back to
that how he started this season
is like an interesting art because you
know he already went down now it's time
for pope
to kind of maybe try to get back up or
maybe he doesn't go up at all you know
who knows i'm interested to see how that
dynamic is going to work out too because
it's like i made it really clear in
episode nine
and then episode 10 i kissed you so it's
like
is it just because it was a rush of
emotions or because i didn't
realize it or what what where does it go
now is it gonna be well that's how i was
gonna do that
or do you think it's real or do you
think it was just kind of like an in the
moment thing
i think the love there is real i think
yeah i just like
at this point i just don't i don't know
like i think pope is just
just as confused as anybody they have a
couple more moments in ten but it's like
it's going to be interesting for them to
like really kind of have to sit down and
talk about what it was and what it is
you know
the conversation i would like to see but
madison people also really like he and
john b
together i'm sure you've seen on social
media as much as people
love kia and john b people love
sarah and jogby i don't know i think
because
we had so many moments in the beginning
and then it just kind of trailed off
i really have no idea where that's at
but i think it was just like hey we're
friends
and i didn't really want to go there
i don't know rudy i'm also sure that
you've seen on social media that people
really want jj to find love
he does he gets a dog
rudy and the dog do you think that that
could be something
not a dog but like another human being
that we see explored in season two maybe
also yeah
i think you know like there's a lot of
talk with
jj and keith there's a lot of talk with
jj and some other girl
i think it is something that's i think
gonna be played with in season two with
jj like slightly throwing like hints of
it
but it's gonna be very very faint like
it's gonna be something that's like
i don't know if it's gonna happen in
season two but it's gonna happen
we'll keep the audience you know hungry
for it maybe even season three is
what happens we'll see do you think he's
capable of a relationship or love or do
you think he's got a lot of things to
figure out first with jj
really feeling abandoned and needing his
friends
maybe there's an arc of him like kind of
going rogue
and not listening to his friends and
then that leaves room for
a love interest and maybe that's how he
comes back to like
or maybe that's how the pokes come back
to him because they come up and be like
this girl's crazy dude you can't be with
her no
no no no no no no yeah leave her you
gotta leave her i mean
aj foster i feel like personally
all of the relationships for everyone
for every single character
to be kind of put on hold no matter what
happens that's like definitely not going
to be the focus in the beginning it's
like
hey let's define the relationship
our friend we think our friends are dead
yeah
that's going to be first yeah for sure
no i don't think it'll ever overtake
like
that what's first is that pogue
friendship pogba
is what's more important and i think
making sure that is whole before
anything else
is what matters most do you think
they're gonna be
upset with john b or do you think
they're just going to want to help him
and i mean your guys's characters are
kind of all considered
accessories in a sense yeah i can see jj
punch and john b in the face
do you guys think that there's legal
ramifications for your characters
also possibly maybe they did steal a
boat
there's attempted battery there's a lot
of stuff we did huh well
ladies and gentlemen pope i mean like
like like we we kicked we kicked it but
like i feel like at that same time we're
also like like
ward's gonna have to come under some
fire too i think like it'll be
interesting seeing the pogue kind of go
into a legal battle against ward cameron
king of the island and it's our word
against his
and you know that class that class thing
that we explored the first season is
really going to come into play
if we get another one for each of you i
mean
rudy you have me a little bit worried
about the journey that you think
your character is going to go on in
season 2 and just kind of being this
like in this dark spot but kind of let
me know like where you guys
want to each go in season two like
things that you want to explore
the pope dynamic is going to be off at
first i don't know if
it's before or after we find out that
zombies alive
i think it'd be kind of necessary to
find that we're going to be okay
before we we find out zombies alive but
i think we need to come back together
and i want to see the pogue
struggle actually to find that it's like
do you remember
who we are before this yeah that's what
we should
be like focusing on i'm excited to
explore that
does sarah deserve to be considered a
pope
yeah at this point at this point she
went into a hurricane
yeah that's pretty like
basically she's basically like shunned
all her money for
for a pogue so that's pretty hard to
calgary right there
it's essentially the same thing kiara
did so
yeah that's true i'm ready for this
revenge
i don't know about you guys it's not
gonna be light it's not gonna be
gentle i'm i'm ready i'm ready for it
i'm ready to see like the poke dynamic
and like us getting revenge on word like
i say the best moments of the show are
when the pogs are together plotting
concocting
when they're concocting it's like that
you get some of your best dialogue you
get some of your best moments
like character like when they bounce off
when the pokes are together it's like
some of the best moments in the show
so yeah again like rudy said getting us
all back together is gonna be like so
much fun to watch
people as you know as we've talked about
do love this show so i'm hoping that you
guys
can each spill a behind-the-scenes
secret
about filming the amount of that we
threw at each other on set like the
amount of time we were just screwing
with each other
it isn't a secret anymore but like yeah
there was definitely a lot of times
where
look we're professional actors but at
the same time we're also
you know pretty immature teenagers are
actually
well we had to get into character
something now to be honest here's the
secret
here's this is the secret part a lot of
actually
that we were doing is in the show like a
lot of times when we didn't know the
cameras was wow
it's in the show
[Music]
when they introduce our characters and
it's like
in episode one it's like this is jj or
like this is open yeah it's like
for mine personally i was watching this
i'm like where were the cameras were
they filming us
like me putting the sunglasses on on
rudy and
us jumping around when were they filming
that yeah
yeah i have no idea there's a lot of
characters
joking around on set and
i then that like we were like roasting
jefferson
i didn't think like they were like
filming they were like filming chase and
they were just like we just want you
guys to sit here and kind of like hang
out
and i had no idea they were filming us
and i called jefferson who is our first
ad
who is the originator of hot damn which
really says in episode
2 he's like yeah that's um
that's jefferson i call him like the
swamp thing i think and like apparently
that made it in
yeah that's a big secret how much how
much bullcrap we did to
each other that just kind of made it in
the show i love that i love the show and
i'm so glad that other people are loving
it do you guys have a message
to all the fans and all the viewers that
you want to send
i just want to say thank you to
everybody watching i mean honestly
not a single part of this would be like
possible
without the fans without the people who
love the show
and we see your videos we see
your little inputs we see your ships we
see all of it and it's like
you're giving you're fueling us for
season two i think that's definitely
gonna be such an energy that's gonna
keep
everybody flowing through season two the
people who like who've
been fans since it first came out on
april 15th who have watched it multiple
times you know
you guys are the reason that like we
want to go making
their season it's just as fun for us to
shoot it is
as it is for you guys to watch it you
know yeah so again thank you guys for
the support exactly what jd says
that's like you guys are being listened
to not just by the cast but also
i want to say probably even netflix is
listening to you guys
uh on all your opinions so uh
but i would i just want to say guys
things might be lining up or that at
least they feel like they're being
lightening up with the coronavirus going
on right now
but we're i just want to be real we're
in this for a while
um it's 2020 is gonna be
kind of hard to get through but i want
to say
as things start opening up again and as
things start to
seem like they're getting better it's
still here so
we gotta stay safe wash those hands but
also keep
groups smaller and the less amount of
people that we infect the less amount of
people that we touch
that could potentially be risk of death
is is still going to be a thing
throughout 2020 so what i want to say is
let's try our very hardest in 2020 to
keep that distance
and so then 2021 can be a banger